holding Birds over there and I'm about
to be holding a burger okay so at Farmer
Boys the customer is always right they
brought back by popular demand some
Classic Limited Edition items to the
menu so Jose Navarro is here to give us
a little today quiet on the set quiet on
the set people
so you're here to give us a taste of the
new items that are or the items that
you're bringing back I should say
absolutely yes I I mean I'm actually
gonna also demonstrate how we make some
of our some of our fresh and very famous
Caesar Salad Wrap okay so what makes
your ingredients so fresh Farmer Boys
all of our ingredients are locally
sourced when possible like that and all
of our vegetables arrive whole what does
that mean you you may ask yeah what does
that mean okay that means that nothing
is pre-backed pre-cut or pre-diced
there's a human behind every one of our
restaurants hand dicing hand cutting in
all of our veggies daily that is so
important because this is necessary it's
you know labeled fast food but it's
fresh fast food yes we love that
absolutely a Caesar wrap because this is
what people were asking to bring back
right yes and I want to let all the
audience know that our Caesar salad and
our Caesar wrap is available until
October 31st okay so time is of the
essence you lose yes so we start our
wrap by using our Fresh Tortillas okay
and then we take freshly diced roaming
um
lettuce and we add some amazing dressing
Caesar dressing you get everything
marinated and together in the back
parmesan cheese for people at home too
packing up school lunches for your kids
yes yeah fresh diced chicken cooked
daily and this is a healthy meal yes
this is a healthy meal and you can't
forget the crew you can't get any better
than that yes
now so what were some of the things you
were hearing from people you know asking
to bring these items back were they like
please bring back the Caesar wrap what
were they saying yeah absolutely exactly
that because it's a classic yeah
everybody likes it but see we had our
own little twists and so this is where
it gets fun we take the salad and we
shake it we shake it like this and
you're seeing the fitness project
product right there on the screen that's
perfect amen
we let it drop just like that oh my gosh
simple as that okay while you're
wrapping that up talk about what else is
on the menu because at Farmer Boys you
can really just get anything you're in
the mood for yes absolutely looking at
these Burgers so here on the display we
have our famous farmer Burger which
consists of a bed of thousand island
dressing onion lettuce tomato pickles uh
quarter pound 100 beef American cheese
absolutely okay go ahead keep Hickory
Hickory bacon and fresh smashed avocado
and talk about this sauce because this
this special sauce is really getting me
right now we make the sauce at home
daily oh my gosh yes that's homemade
sauce and we also have our barn burner
which is a spicy it it'll get you
running man and I want to talk about
what kind of running yeah running for
water that is uh the sauce that is
inside of this burger is also made fresh
and home I love it thank you so much
absolutely go ahead hold that up hold up
yes yes that will fill you up okay and
you said these items are on the menu
until October 31st October 31st